les négociations au coeur du message des
manuels macron général trinquant bonjour
et merci de répondre à ces quelques
questions vous êtes ancien chef de la
mission militaire française auprès des
nations unies et emmanuel macron on
répète qu'il faut des négociations entre
russes et ukrainiens il se défend si de
toute complaisance avec poutine pour il
assume en quelque sorte la position de
la france soutient à l'ukraine tout en
maintenant le dialogue avec la russie
est tenable à long terme à long terme
c'est la seule position qui étonna bhl
il faut bien voir la séquence soutenir
l'ukraine pour qu'elle résiste voir
qu'elle gagne
deuxièmement cessez-le-feu troisièmement
négociations je vois difficilement
comment on peut faire autrement je ne
vois pas aujourd'hui l'ukraine est en
mesure de gagner complètement c'est à
dire revenir aux frontières
internationales d'avant 2014 mais
résiste et oui et ensuite il faudra bien
négocier avec lui avec la russie ce qui
sera très difficile et si on ne lui
maintient pas le lien de communication
je vois difficilement comment on peut
négocier ce lien avec poutine il a servi
à quoi pour l'instant il a servi à
maintenir le lien le président l'a
répété plusieurs fois il est intervenu
auprès du président poutine à la demande
du président ps qui à chaque fois et
donc il fallait maintenir ce lien de
communication mais comme vous le dites
ça n'a pas forcément pour l'instant
porté des fruits vous avez des disparus
général trinquant mais on vous entend
toujours
ces négociations là il va falloir
convaincre aussi les les ukrainiens qui
veulent continuer là vous voir vous
revoilà ils veulent continuer le
la guerre ils veulent aller
reconquérir le dombass récupérer la
crimée et ça ce sera aussi un élément à
prendre en compte
alors le premier point c'est plutôt que
de penser à reconquérir il faut déjà
arrêter pour l'instant les russes
progress dans le donbass ils sont en
train de saisir cbre de ness et donc le
louarn sq et donc il faut les arrêter
impérativement oui et ensuite peut-être
monter les contre attaques quand l'armée
ukrainienne aura reçu tous les
équipements nécessaires et aura la
capacité
mais ont pour l'instant on en est au
stade de la résistance est à terme il
faudra négocier le président le
président aulas qui lui-même lors des
négociations d'istanbul parlait déjà du
fait qu'il sera difficile de négocier le
retour de la crimée à l'ukraine donc je
ne sais pas ce que ali trend est capable
de négocier avec la russie c'est à elle
de le décider mais il faudra négocier
c'est certain on attend l'arrivée
d'emmanuel macron en moldavie ce
déplacement bon il vise bien sûr à
rassurer ce pays qui n'est pas membre de
l'union européenne qui met pas membres
de l'otan quels risques de débordement
du conflit pour la moldavie aujourd'hui
alors la moldavie est dans une situation
particulière une se veut une situation
qui est similaire à l'ukraine
puisqu'elle ne fait partie ni le temps
ni de l'union européenne ceci étant elle
est aux frontières de l'ukraine et elle
a à une partie très petit il faut bien
le reconnaître mais qui est séparatiste
et qui est du côté russe donc c'est une
zone fragile et l'union européenne veut
apporter le soutien que la moldavie
demande
pour la soutenir en cas de crise je ne
crois pas beaucoup à une attaque russe
sachant que les deux bataillons qui sont
en moldavie sont des territoriaux qui
n'ont pas avait-elle vraiment de
capacités de combat mais il faut
rassurer la moldavie est peut-être lui
donner les perspectives de rejoindre
l'union européenne à terme général train
quand on attend toujours confirmation ou
pas d'une éventuelle
visite des manuels macron demain ou dans
les prochains jours en ukraine tout
indique qu'il fera ce déplacement le
contraire serait une erreur selon vous
alors je pense qu'il ne le président le
dit depuis le début il s'agit d'aller en
ukraine si cela est utile il s'agit pas
d'y aller pour faire une séance de
photographie il a prévu d'y aller
normalement d'après les informations qui
sont disponibles avec le chancelier
allemand et le premier ministre italien
ce serait très utile parce qu'on le sait
la france l'italie et l'allemagne sont
les pays qui sont les rêves plus
qu'ils sont moteurs disons pour une
négociation avec la russie et il s'agit
de montrer l'unité de l'ensemble de
l'europe en soutien à l'ukraine dans une
perspective future de soutien l'ukraine
peut-être pour rejoindre à terme comme
la moldavie l'union européenne mais pour
l'instant de combattre contre la réussi
à vendre des négociations depuis cette
entame et on verra si l'élysée confirme
ou pas ce déplacement merci mr en
général trinquant d'ailleurs répondu à
ces quelques questions